the 2008 financial crisis was
devastating but the silver lining is
that it shed light onto some of the
biggest mods and shortfalls of the
industry
of course most of the largest players
faced no consequences but many mid-sized
perpetrators got obliterated one of
these perpetrators was a hedge fund
named absolute capital management run by
florian homme
up until 2008 absolute capital
management or acm was one of the fastest
growing hedge funds in the world and
florian was regarded as an investing
genius
the fund managed roughly 3 billion at
their peak and they were crushing the s
p 500 year after year but in late 2007
florian could sense that a storm was
coming and that his facade was about to
crumble
so he stuffed 500 000 into his underwear
and fled the us
acm subsequently crashed 93 by june of
2008 and the sec would charge florian
with 200 million worth of investment
fraud
since then florian has been on the fbi's
most wanted list but to this day the fbi
hasn't been able to serve him justice
and it's not like they don't know where
he is either
everyone knows that he's living in
germany and he even does interviews to
this day claiming his innocence but
despite this the fbi has been able to do
nothing
so here's the story of how florian hom
stole 200 million dollars and
successfully escaped the fda's most
wanted list
taking a look back florian was born on
october 7th 1959 in a small town near
frankfurt germany called obersol growing
up florian had a pretty nice childhood
as his father was a rather successful
businessman florian's father had built
up a pipe building and a bathroom
feeding installation business that was
quite lucrative though florian was
grateful for the business he had no
interest in following his father into
the business to florian welding pipes
and installing bathroom fixtures sounded
extremely boring something that did
interest him though was his great uncle
joseph neckerman joseph was not only
filthy rich but he was a superstar
joseph was an equestrian olympic athlete
who had won two gold medals two silver
medals and two bronze medals he also won
two world championships and four
european championships and on top of all
of this joseph started germany's largest
mail-order business at the time and
employed 30 000 employees
so if joseph were alive today he would
basically be a billionaire olympian
joseph hosted a family gathering at his
mansion every sunday and florian recalls
that these visits are what convinced
florian that he had to be rich just like
his great uncle and with that in mind
flooring would be sent off to the us
where he attended bentley high school in
michigan florian ended up crushing high
school and would be accepted into
harvard university where he got a
bachelor's and an mba and following his
studies florence scored a job at the
prestigious merrill lynch he would work
here for a couple of years but he would
eventually switch over to fidelity
investments where he got the opportunity
to work under and be personally trained
by peter lynch after leveraging this
phenomenal opportunity lauren moved back
to germany where he would become a
senior vice president at julius bar i
think most of us would agree that
florian was already killing it but his
ambitions were much larger so florian
would go ahead and start his first
company in 1993
florian's first company was called value
management and research and it was based
in frankfurt germany at first glance the
company is just another one in the mill
hedge fund but florence charm is what
would really attract investors you see
florian had a very peculiar investing
philosophy he believed that the
traditional hedge funds were doing it
all wrong with their fancy algorithms
and complex mathematics florian believed
that it was much better to approach
investing holistically for example
instead of basing your investments on
quarterly reports with holistic
investing you would base your
investments on the impact and influence
of the company this isn't exactly a new
idea as long-term investors often tend
to be more holistic anyway but for a
hedge fund this was definitely out of
the ordinary florian chose a couple of
internet and technology hype stocks to
invest in and thanks to the dotcom
bubble these stocks would explode
florian became iconic for these
investments and these stocks were often
referred to as home stocks moving past
the dot-com bubble florin began to spend
his newfound fortune in 2004 for
instance he invested 20 million euros
into the german soccer club or russia
dartmouth the soccer team was nearly
bankrupt and was suffering from terrible
management so when florian invested 20
million and over to the old management
he was held as a hero by many soccer
fans florian would leverage his media
attention to start a new hedge fund in
2005 and that brings us into the
infamous absolute capital management acm
launched a great fanfare and gave
florian's popularity charm and holistic
investment strategy investors flooded in
acm did have quite a few winning picks
but they were all quite odd florian
wasn't investing into apple or amazon
one of his most famous investments was
actually a berlin brothel called artemis
such weird choices simply garnered acm
even more attention and alternative
investment news would even name acm as
the hedge fund leader of the year by
2007 acm had grown to three billion
dollars in assets and florida's personal
fortune was worth 700 million dollars
but it wasn't all good as florence great
world also attracted negative attention
one day in 2006 as florian was traveling
through the streets of carrickas
venezuela he would be stopped by a group
of armed men the armed men demanded
everything florin had on him which
included his wallet mobile phone and
watch florian quickly handed over his
phone and wallet but he didn't want to
part with his watch when florian tried
negotiating to keep his watch though the
armed men started shooting florian was
shot in his chest and ended up losing
most of his left lung and spleen but
thanks to emergency surgery florian was
able to survive while it seems like this
was simply a robbery that went bad
florian is convinced that this was an
assassination attempt and there is good
reason to believe this first of all
florian was not traveling alone he was
traveling with his bodyguard and driver
not only did the bodyguard do a poor job
by protecting foreign but he was shot in
a much more non-lethal way the bodyguard
was shot in the knee and the driver
wasn't shot at all so it's possible that
the bodyguard and or driver were working
with the robbers something else to
consider is that in most cases robbers
aren't looking to hurt you they simply
want your money and being wanted for
homicide is much more risky than simply
being wanted for robbery so it's odd
that the robbers were so willing to open
fire especially in a lethal way despite
the sketchiness of the situation it was
never determined if this really was a
failed assassination attempt or simply
idiot robbers this experience did
however lead florian to re-evaluate his
life choices florian says that he had
all the money he could ever need but he
was wasting his life working 16 hours a
day six days a week he could afford all
the luxuries he wanted but he didn't
have the time to actually enjoy them so
in september of 2007 florian announced
that he would be selling his stake in
acm and retiring
this was a bit of a douchebag move as
this 40 million stock sale crashed the
stock 75 from 2 billion to 500 million
but anyway after the sale florian would
spread this money across 120 bank
accounts located in four different
continents and he would flee the
on his flight out of the u.s florian
carried 500 000 in his underwear and his
accomplice carried another 700 thousand
this was no doubt a pretty sketchy way
to leave but many were still sympathetic
towards florian given his near-death
experience in reality though florian had
just gotten away with one of the biggest
frauds in u.s history
despite all the positive press acm was
receiving the entire fund was basically
a scam foreign was literally operating
fraud on top of fraud on top of fraud
and the sec was catching on the first
form of fraud foreign was running was
the classic penny stock pump and dump
between 2004 and 2006 foreign had been
using his massive cash reserves to buy
up low-balling penny stocks and dump
them onto uneducated investors aside
from running a pump and dump flooring
had a clever way to make even more money
on the side you see fluorine have set up
a secondary company that was responsible
for executing trades for acm and this
company charged insanely high fees so
not only was florian making money on the
pump and dump itself but he was making
money executing trades for the pump and
dumps not all of asem's investments were
in pump and dumps but even the non-bump
and dump stocks had fraud written all
over them
for example florian and his partners
would regularly trade stocks amongst
themselves to inflate the daily volume
of these stocks and make it seem like
these stocks were way more popular than
they really were acm also had
investments in private companies and
given that these shares were not traded
publicly it was acm's job to provide
their investors with a fair evaluation
for these companies but as you would
guess the valuations that acm told their
investors were way inflated looking back
there were a bunch of red flags running
acm from the very beginning acm was
posting insane growth numbers during a
relatively stagnant time following the
dot-com crash not to mention acm was
registered in the cayman islands anyway
the sec did eventually catch on and the
fbi would file criminal charges against
florian in march 2013 but florian had
already lived a free life for six years
and he had no intention of changing that
warren wasn't able to just walk away
from the fbi though just two days after
the fbi filed criminal charges they were
able to locate florian in italy and
arrest him from the very beginning it
seemed like florian's plan was to just
battle against extradition his lawyers
argued that florian suffered from
multiple sclerosis and that he couldn't
be incarcerated due to health concerns
the fbi played along and fought back
against florence lawyers with the
doctors that testified that florence
condition did not prevent incarceration
it seemed like the fbi was winning as
the court would side with the fbi and
agreed to extradite foreign which meant
up to a 225 year long prison sentence
while the fbi was celebrating florian
had a completely different plan to get
out
you see italy actually has a rule that
once next tradition becomes final the
prisoner must be extradited within 45
days or they're released from prison
it's not clear if stalling was a 200 iq
move from florian or if it was simply an
oversight from the fbi
but either way foreign would be released
from prison on june 23rd 2014.
as soon as he was released he bought a
train ticket to florence where his
lawyers picked him up and took him to
germany florian crossed the german
border the following day and this
officially marked his freedom you see it
germany has a strict policy of not
extracting german citizens and since the
german courts don't have any arrest
warrants against florian florian is a
free man as long as he stays in germany
florian is still on the fbi's most
wanted list but the fbi has avoided
extraditing him by force because they
don't want to ruin relations with the
germany
in the meantime florian has become a
completely different man he says that
his year in italian prison it completely
changes outlook on life he's transparent
that what he did at acm was completely
immoral and unethical but he still holds
that he didn't break any laws
florian has become a strong christian
and spends most of his time sharing his
knowledge and donating his money
for example he published a book called
rogue financier and he donated 100 of
their profits to the library renaissance
foundation he also co-founded a charity
called our lady's message of mercy to
the world foundation he even has his own
youtube channel where he discusses his
thoughts on the world the economy and
the stock market on a regular basis so
florian has turned into more of a wolf a
wall street type figure as opposed to a
bernie madoff type figure still some
people argue that florian should be
extradited to the us and jailed for his
crimes while others argue that what
flooring is doing now is a much better
way to repay society instead of just
rotting in jail which camp are you in
comment that down below
also drop a like if you're glad that
florian is at least changing his ways
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and continue to subscribe
and see more questions logically
answered but until then i'm hari and
i'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]
you